A
DISASTER ON EVERY SINGLE LEVEL,
AND NOVEMBER FRANKLY CAN'T COME
SOON ENOUGH.
HERE WITH REACTION, OHIO
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN, ALONG
WITH WITHOUT KICK FOUNDERED CLAY
TRAVIS BEARD CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
TAKE A BOW, SIR, YOU HELPED GET
RID OF THE ADMINISTRATOR KNOW MF
TRUTH.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT, BAD
IDEA.
WE WILL WORK TOGETHER ON IT, AS
KAMALA SAYS.
>> WITH THE DISINFORMATION
GOVERNMENT SENT KNOW MY
GOVERNANCE HAVE FACT-CHECKED THE
PERSONAL CARE IN FRONT OF OUR
COMEDIANS AND MEN CAN GET
PREGNANT HAVE AN ABORTION?
I ALMOST AM SAD AND WISH WE HAVE
WAITED A DAY BEFORE THEY
DISBANDED THE BOARD TO SEE
EXACTLY WHAT NINA JANKOWICZ
WOULD HAVE SAID TO THAT
RIDICULOUS STATEMENT MADE IN THY
BY THE DEMOCRAT WITNESS, SO
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU HAVE
DONE AND THE WORK CLAY HAS DONE
ON HIS RADIO SHOW, AS WELL.
>> Sean: AND CLAY, I THINK
WHAT WE ARE REALLY GETTING DOWN
TO, OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE, I
ALWAYS LIKED CARL CAMERON,
ACTUALLY, THANKS WIM OUGHT TO BE
PUTTING PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR
MISINFORMATION, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED TO CARL, NOT THE
GUY I KNEW WHEN HE WORKED HERE,
IT IS GETTING CRAZY, BUT I
BELIEVE THE TARGET OF THIS IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE
CONSERVATIVES.
LIBERALS ARE NEVER CALLED OUT.
THREE YEARS, LYING, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
NEVER MIND WHAT HAPPENED TO
NICHOLAS SANDMANN, NEVER MIND
WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL THE OTHER
CASES THAT WERE WRONG, FROM
RICHARD JEWELL TO CAMBRIDGE
POLICE TO FERGUSON TO BALTIMORE
AND FREDDIE GRAY, DUKE LACROSSE,
UVA, THEY GET IT ALL WRONG ALL
THE TIME, AND THEY ARE NEVER
HELD ACCOUNTABLE, AND THEY NEVER
RETRACT THEIR REMARKS,
APOLOGIZE, OR MAKE A CORRECTION,
EVER.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, SEAN.
AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
CONGRESSMEN, I SAW THAT CLIP AND
MY JAW DROPPED.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN MEDIA THAT WATCH
YOUR SHOW, SEAN, AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO START ASKING ALL
DEMOCRATS, CAN MEN GET PREGNANT?
AND CAN THEY HAVE ABORTIONS?
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
PRETTY SETTLED FACT, AND WE'VE
GOT DEMOCRATS UNDER OATH IN
FRONT OF THE CONGRESSMAN HERE
SAYING THAT MEN CAN IN FACT GET
PREGNANT AND HAVE ABORTIONS --
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT --
>> DOES JOE BIDEN THINK THAT?
>> Sean: I'M GOING TO LET YOU
PICK UP THAT THOUGHT.
LET ME JUST PLAY IT BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK PEOPLE HAVE SEEN
THIS ENOUGH.
>> YES.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY WOMAN IS?
>> I BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE CAN
IDENTIFY FOR THEMSELVES.
>> OKAY.
DO YOU BELIEVE THEN THAT MEN CAN
BECOME PREGNANT AND HAVE
ABORTIONS?
>> YES.
>> Sean: THERE YOU GO, CLAY.
I AM LEARNING SOMETHING NEW
EVERY DAY.
>> IF PEOPLE HAVE NOT SEEN THIS,
IT IS SO UNBELIEVABLE WHAT IS
GOING ON.
THINK ABOUT THIS FOR A MINUTE,
SEAN, AND ALSO JIM, WE'VE GOT
JEFF BEZOS, WHO RUNS
"THE WASHINGTON POST," NOW
FEUDING WITH JOE BIDEN BECAUSE
OF HOW INCOMPETENT THEY ARE ON
ECONOMIC POLICY.
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON,
ELON MUSK CAME OUT AND SAID I'M
LEAVING BEHIND THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY BECAUSE THEY ARE TOTALLY
LOSING THEIR MINDS, AND I THINK
WE ARE STARTING TO STACK SOME
WINS, SEAN, AND CONGRESSMAN,
THINK ABOUT THIS, CNN PLUS
COLLAPSES, THE MINISTRY OF TRUTH
DIDN'T EVEN LAST AS LONG AS CNN
PLUS DID, YOU GOT ELON MUSK
BUYING TWITTER, AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE DATA ON SOME OF THESE
PRIMARIES, GEORGIA,
PENNSYLVANIA, NORTH CAROLINA,
REPUBLICAN VOTERS ARE COMING OUT
AND THEY ARE ENERGIZED AND THEY
ARE EXCITED AND IT IS BECAUSE
THEY ARE FIGHTING AGAINST
INSANITY.
THERE ARE CIRCLE PARTIES RIGHT
NOW, THE INSANE PARTY WHICH IS
THE DEMOCRATS, AND THE SAME
PARTY WHICH IS THE REPUBLICAN
SPIRITS BE 187, JIM JORDAN, OF
THE TOP THREE VOTE GETTERS, THEY
ALL CLAIMED TO BE MAGA CANDIDATN
PENNSYLVANIA, AMAZING.
THEN YOU LOOK AT TRUMP'S RECORD
DEPENDING ON WHETHER YOU THINK
HIS COMMENTS WERE AN ENDORSEMENT
OF MADISON CAWTHORN, HE IS
EITHER 81 AND THREE OR 81-AMP
TWO, MEANING 81 VICTORIES, AND
WHAT ELON MUSK SAID, IN THE PAST
I VOTED DEMOCRAT BECAUSE THEY
WERE MOSTLY THE KINDNESS PARTY,
HE WROTE, BUT THEY HAVE BECOME A
PARTY OF DIVISION AND HATE SO I
CAN NO LONGER SUPPORT THEM, AND
WILL VOTE REPUBLICAN.
NOW WATCH THE DIRTY TRICKS
CAMPAIGN AGAINST ME UNFOLD.
HE IS RIGHT ABOUT ALL POINTS.
>> NO, EXACTLY.
LOOK, THE TRUMP ENDORSEMENT IS
THE MOST POWERFUL POLITICAL
ENDORSEMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY
WITHOUT A DOUBT, WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
THE COUNTRY HAS COMMON SENSE, AS
CLAY POINTED OUT, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS THE PARTY OF
COMMON SENSE AND REGULAR PEOPLE,
DEPART KNOW MY DEMOCRAT PARTY IS
THE PARTY OF CRAZINESS.
THERE'S A REASON 7 OUT OF 10
BELIEVE THE COUNTRIES ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'VE EVER SEEN
NUMBERS THAT BAD, BECAUSE
AMERICA HAS COME IN SENSE AND
THE UNDERSTAND -- JERRY NADLER,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, HAD TO APPROVE THAT
WITNESS.
THEY WENT OUT AND GOT THAT
WITNESS TO COME TESTIFY.
THAT SHOWS YOU HOW OUT OF TOUCH
THEY ARE WITH REALITY AND WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND WHY I
THINK AS YOU SAID AND AS CLAY
SAID, IT IS GOING TO BE A
GOOD NIGHT FOREIGN REPUBLICANS
ON NOVEMBER 8 AND A GOOD NIGHT
FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Sea